Richard was in here telling me Gary has
a huge nose hair sticking out today look
I don't see anything crazy enormous
right nostril oh yeah picture coalition
season Jason's right into he loves booth
come on Gary all of a sudden he's a
[ __ ] professional photographer yeah
you gotta clip those things like at
least once a week I had dude I used that
nail trimmer I did it on an ultra
Saturday the thing that you put on your
feet your fungus me another thing that
you know that world like an electric and
God knows trimmer that's not a nail
trimmer I think you speak so fast you
called your a [ __ ] if he pulls it out
you'll sneeze that's why I make myself
sneeze by pulling out my nasal hairs but
do you sometimes cry Richard pull out
his hair up but you know I love it I
love it I love to sneeze but I haven't
be really brave Wow that was a pretty
good moment on camera put that up on
Instagram hurt hey Richard use your hair
Richard you're supposed to make a wish
trim his nose hairs more time Wow let me
see it oh let me see that oh my god it's
great his nose hair is white oh my god
eat it well why'd you put it in your
mouth taste the thoughts
guys tickle in my throat oh my why did
you get I was kidding oh oh oh that's
[ __ ] vile right
it's literally tickle in the back of my
tongue just swallowed this massive nose
hair oh Jesus